In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for August 20th, on which we commemorate, St. Stephen,
First King of Hungary, a direct descendant of Arpad, the conqueror of Panonia, St. Stephen
was born in about the year 970, in Strigonium, Estrugom. His maternal grandfather, Guila,
had been baptized in Constantinople with the name Stephen, Emperor Constantine VII,
Porphyrogenitos, standing Godfather to him. Having firmly decided to spread Orthodoxy
throughout his land, he took St. Jerotheos to be with him, to become the first bishop of
the Hungarians. Baptized in childhood, the young Stephen was influenced by St. Adelbert,
Bishop of Prague, who was martyred by the Prussians in the year 997.
Profiting from the conquests by his grandfather and father, and having himself carried off great
victories over the pagan princes, he became the first king of the Hungarian nation and received
the crown from Pope Silvestre II and Otto III, Emperor of the West, on the feast of the
nativity in the year 1000 or 2001. Having married Giselle, princes of Bavaria and sister
of Emperor Henry II, he spent his time from then on not only in organizing the nascent state
and preserving the cultural identity of his people, but also in deepening the Christianization
that had until then only been superficially introduced by Western missionaries.
He divided the land into six dioceses and founded a great many churches and monasteries, both
Greek and Latin, which the royal couple richly endowed with all that was necessary for
divine worship. He edited two books of decrees, which testified to the king's desire to
regulate all the aspects of his people's lives in accordance with the gospel.
He also wrote exhortations to his son Emmerich, whose education he had confided to the monk
Gerard, who had lived earlier in a Venetian monastery before becoming a hermit, and he
was then consecrated Bishop of Sanad and died a martyr near Pest in the year 1046.
Desirous of encouraging pilgrimage to the holy places, St. Stephen built a number of
hospices for pilgrims, not only in his own country, but also in Jerusalem, Constantinople,
Rome and Ravenna. His devotion to the most holy mother of God was without
parallel, and it was to her heavenly protection that the king equal to the apostles confided
hungry. He also dedicated the first monastery of Greek nuns in Vesprim to the most holy,
and the principal church in the kingdom of Shekhis Fechervar, Alba.
Renowned throughout Europe for his piety, King Stephen was strict towards the enemies of
the faith, but knew how to be magnanimous to the conquered. In the year 1030 he was forced
to take arms, to repulse an invasion by Conrad II. Once peace was restored, he returned
to his capital, but had the anguish of seeing his only son and heir Emmerich die. He spent
the last years of his earthly sojourn in peace, and after having taken care of the succession,
fell asleep in the Lord on the 15th of August in the year 1038, being buried in the church
in Shekhis Fechervar. When his relics were found in the year 1083, his right hand was discovered
intact and is today venerated in St. Stephen's church in Budapest. Through the prayers of our
Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.